[Música]
hola como estan go full gente bueno si
soy raúl santana no me conocen por ese
nombre en la mayoría sí pero bueno si
soy bueno realmente es el tecnólogo
realización de actuación y la asociación
de cine y actuación para cine y
televisión también bueno soy tecnólogo
en música y composición soy
hice un año de arquitectura y llevo diez
años involucrado en el medio del show
bussiness como le digo yo estamos a
mensajes que adiós pero es la verdad
yo business este país entonces lleva
involucrado más de diez años en eso seis
años con el elenco de enchufe tv cinco
años trabajando como parte fija de la
empresa como dijeron los chicos por
muchas paz pasé por muchas partes
ingresen inicialmente como asistente de
dirección luego fui a posproducción
luego fui asistente y ferb y asistente
de iluminación y las partes técnicas y
de cámara luego fui productor asistente
de producción aparte de todo esto sería
cuando maquillaje los últimos dos años
dice la gerencia de producción de vtv
desde el 2017 y el 2018 y terminamos en
dos semanas de grabar esta temporada ya
se acabe este año para nosotros y
retornamos del próximo año a partir de
la segunda semana de febrero nuestro
trabajo porque también tenemos que tener
en el día de hoy para hablar de redes
sociales y les quiero realmente yo esto
no es que lo estudie tanto pero es una
cosa que se volvió un parte que conozco
mucho debido a mi trabajo yo estudié
cine para hacer películas y terminé
haciendo youtube no pero que es súper
cool no no no no lo digo en un aspecto
en un aspecto muy bueno porque hacer una
película cuesta mucho y es súper
complicado para nosotros el otro día
estamos hablando con los chicos de
producción y me puse a ver como el
conteo de tiempo si sumamos todo lo que
hemos hecho en enchufe tenemos que así
las películas hechas a lo largo de estos
siete años más o menos hemos hecho
sumando todo el material de making of y
todas esas cosas son como 10 películas
es como haber hecho una serie de seis
temporadas con 22 episodios cada una de
45 intro duración lo que hemos hecho
hasta ahora sí así soy perdón se ríe no
a ver es que así soy así funciona mi
cabecita por eso me pusieron en
producción porque así funciona mi
cerebro redes sociales la verdad yo
siempre hacerlas no sé qué decir y le
estoy súper honesto yo soy así perdón el
mismo me voy a sentar ahí porque el
zapato hasta que me escándalo en el
talón
e
mis charlas ahorita vamos a la parte su
perte cual que es una red social cuando
pregunte que querían que hable me
dijeron redes sociales pero que es súper
ante el tema especificada que pero bueno
vamos a hablar de redes sociales y lo
que vamos a hacer es ahorita les va a
dar como todo esto que yo les
representara horita ustedes lo puede
encontrar en internet ya y me sorprende
me sorprendería si no supieran porque si
están aquí es porque le interesa debería
saberlo pero en fin y después vamos
literalmente me va a sentar ahí y quiero
que ustedes preguntan que quieren saber
porque de verdad
puedo pararme aquí por horas y decirles
un montón de cosas pero si no es lo que
ustedes vinieron a buscar de mí el día
de hoy no sirvió de nada entonces es lo
que vamos a hacer ahorita mismo súper
rápido ya y esta parte yo yo cuando
estaba armando está dije guau
eres consciente de esto por el trabajo y
ver los números de las estadísticas ves
las cosas pero nunca estás tan
consciente como cuando ves estos números
veremos si funcionan
es una red social es un servicio un
servicio redes sociales un medio de
comunicación social que nos permite
establecer contacto con otras personas
por medio de un sitio web usualmente son
más familia y su propósito es conectar a
personas que son usuarios que todos
nosotros somos que comparten alguna
relación principalmente amistad
mantienen interés actividades en común o
se encuentran interesados en explorar
intereses y las actividades de otros
usuarios
por eso básicamente todos abrimos haifa
cuando por el 2004-2005
yo tenía facebook si me veo chiquito
pero no tengo ya casi 30 años entonces
yo sí descubrí todo eso
ok estas son las estadísticas que les
puede sacar de enero del 2018
relevantes de la parte de conexión redes
sociales de internet de uso del planeta
primero vamos a enfocarnos en el uso del
mundo y lo vamos a enfocarnos
directamente en ecuador que es lo que
nosotros
de la población total del mundo que son
los 7.5 93 billones de personas 12 a 7
mil 593 mil millones de personas
estamos totalmente 55 por ciento
organizados y de esos el 53 por ciento
es usuario de internet en el mundo estoy
hablando de esto que de los cuales el 42
por ciento de todo esto es la activa en
redes sociales el 68 por ciento de las
personas tienen un teléfono únicamente
de uso pero de ese el 39 por ciento son
las personas que usan activamente las
redes sociales en su teléfono con
nosotros
teherán en facebook y todas esas cosas
cuáles son las cosas más las
aplicaciones de las redes sociales más
utilizadas de nivel mundial facebook es
el rey indiscutible más de 2 mil
millones de usuarios a nivel mundial
segundo viene youtube tercero whatsapp y
cuarto messenger nos vamos a enfocar
sólo en esos porque el resto ya son
variaciones por eso están con diferentes
colores naranjas son redes sociales los
rojos son métodos de comunicación rápida
y mensajería instantánea básicamente
pero se convirtieron en redes sociales
porque ahora podemos mandar fotos videos
tenemos perfiles tenemos estados y eso
ya lo que es una red social que no sólo
hablas intercambias gustos
feizbuk grave en el 2004 por mark
zuckenberg originalmente ideado como un
método de comunicación interno para sólo
la gente de harvard y después ya en el
la mayoría de personas que utilizan esta
red está entre los 20 y 35 años el único
requisito que necesitas es un correo
electrónico a veces un correo
electrónico pone esa clave tienes un
facebook es fácil cuantos tienen
facebook y levanten la mano
perfecto cuantos usan facebook que aquí
el acorde a la estadística
y bueno me decía es la más grande del
mundo esto está fuente es igual de lo
que le saqué antes de las estadísticas
de hootsuite hours social que salieron
en enero de 2018 obviamente ahorita
estamos ya con mi gobierno de 2010 de
pendientes y 2018 por ende las
estadísticas han cambiado un poco el
porcentaje estamos hablando de que
subieron de 12 puntos en porcentual
de todo lo que les estoy teniendo
ahorita y ahorita en enero del 2019 sale
la nueva estadística que estos manes
también van a hacerlo
youtube creado en el 2005 el primer
vídeo que se llama mi arte su vista y la
vista
yo he visto
youtube fue creado por cinco ex socios
de paypal bien ahí ustedes y es la
segunda red social más grande del mundo
es la plataforma más grande de vídeo del
planeta es esa hay vídeos y ahora
podemos subir fotos y estados han visto
también que hay fotos y estados en
youtube entonces así los creadores de
contenido pueden decir como el lunes
mire en subir un vídeo para poner el
link pero vi desde hace tres semanas y
le sigue dando tráfico pilas youtube
tenemos la mayor cantidad de usuarios
son de 18 teeti 4 años el único
requisito es que tú mismo que este
contenido en un vídeo y sólo subas
mil quinientos mil quinientos millones
de usuarios es más de un tercio de la
población del mundo estamos y perón una
otra estadística que les iba a dar súper
éxitos a ningún canal de televisión
supera la audiencia que tiene el
contenido de youtube en eeuu así de
masivas de cuestión al menos allá que es
donde más paga whatsapp mensajería
instantánea creado en el 2009 por jean
one y puede mandar mensajes de texto
tienes fotos tienes documentos tienen
llamadas de vídeo llamadas sólo con voz
desde hace cuánto un año más o menos que
estamos con eso
algunas veces funcionan de maravilla
otras veces no funcionan pero estamos en
eso todavía requisito tienes que tener
un número telefónico por fax cuando
estaba haciendo esta investigación me
enteré que recientemente en un nuevo
conteos algunas estadísticas mundiales
existen más chips de teléfono que
humanos en el planeta ahora porque la
gente ahora ya no tienes alguna línea
ahora tenemos varias y es mínimo en al
menos en el ecuador en toda familia
existe un dispositivo móvil con conexión
internet y uso de redes sociales
1300 millones de usuarios
messenger de facebook yo también dije
que pero si está que pasó facebook en el
2008 dijo ok estoy cobrando por
advertising en mi página en mi como se
llama él
en el historial que parece no cierto
entonces lo que hicieron fue recuerden
que en el inicio tenía esto incorporado
con el facebook que era una viñeta nada
más que dabas clic y se abría y seguía
chateando bueno lo que se hizo para
teléfonos celulares fue hacerle dos
cosas diferentes simplemente para tener
más ganancias porque también publicitas
por medio de esta aplicación duplica sus
ganancias sin necesidad de crear nada
más que ya estaba creado
igual fotos videos llamadas documentos
tienen los propios de moody's tienes las
caritas y que son medias raras pero cada
uno uso siquiera unos 1200 millones de
usuarios es del 60% de los usuarios de
facebook que están aquí
y todo está camión en el 2009 cuando las
primeras empresas en europa empezaron a
hacer publicidad en las redes sociales y
dijeron guau espérate hay tanta gente
aquí conectada pasan todo el día
conectados dándose likes dándose pocs en
ese entonces hasta ahora te puedes dar
pero ya no sé dónde están yo pero en ese
entonces era como súper común ay me picó
empezó bien así empezó
la publicidad y ahí fue cuando todo el
mundo nos interesamos en esto
porque dices wow es rentable hay plata y
hay si todo el mundo porque si es que
esto no se pudiera monetizar a nadie le
interesaría ninguno de nosotros tenemos
aquí ahorita es la verdad y por eso
quiero que empiezan a preguntar
rápidamente vamos a ver en el ecuador
así como súper por encima para entender
qué es esto pero de quiero que me den
sus preguntas porque creo que la mayoría
de aquí está como no sé qué se sabe
porque mi cabeza puede decir como por mi
trabajo y las cosas el ambiente que soy
acostumbrado siempre tal vez les voy a
hablar en parte de ok genera plata cobra
engagement y esto y esto y esto me
entienden y tal vez no es lo que quieren
saber entonces llamamos de la jce
ecuador guau
ok la presión está total somos 16 puntos
7 millones de esos el 80% tiene acceso a
internet el 13.47 mejoro full porque en
el censo en los documentos del 2016
apenas el 25% del país tenía acceso a
internet en ese entonces y ahora estamos
en un 80 por ciento hemos mejorado de
esos 11 millones al 66% somos activos en
redes sociales
el 91% tenemos conexiones de telefonía y
conexiones móviles perdón y 10 millones
son activos usuarios de redes sociales
en dispositivos móviles
el uso de internet el número total de
personas activas en internet en el
ecuador es de 13.47 millones de personas
como porcentaje de la población
repetimos es del 80% y este es el
incremento que hemos tenido en el del
año pasado ahora cómo se desarrolló la
tecnología y el empuje que le dieron las
redes sociales a la adquisición
tecnológica y mejora tecnológica en
nuestra tenemos un incremento del 3 por
ciento el año pasado en adquisición de
laptops y computadoras
tienes bueno los teléfonos se dejaron de
vender porque porque incrementaron las
consolas ahora los chicos se conectan a
netflix en facebook o en youtube desde
su playstation ya no lo ven desde su
laptop lo ves desde tu ipad ya no lo ves
desde tu laptop o desde tu pc o desde tu
teléfono lo ves porque ya estás
que si hacemos son estos quien va al
baño sin celular levante la mano el que
va al baño sin celular gracias
y también disminuye la venta de los
tablets en 22% porque aumentaron los
dispositivos de juego
y estos son los resultados de las cosas
que más buscan así la sociedad escritor
jana en el internet primero está
google.com punto s
guau youtube google facebook el comercio
live.com que es básicamente messenger y
hotmail ahora es live teleamazonas ya
hub ecuavisa wikipedia el noticiero
y estas son las top google sites
facebook ecuador youtube traductor obvio
hotmail google música iniciación en
facebook vengo pichincha y escribo lx
mp3 repente cometido esto es muy
interesante que una marca como banco el
pichincha pichincha o lx aparezcan en
estas búsquedas porque son apenas las
primeras marcas que vemos no ha habido
nada más nosotros son canal de
televisión que son medios de difusión
masiva se consideran plataformas más no
redes sociales aplicaciones pero esto sí
se podría considerar como ser influencia
de las redes sociales para las búsquedas
y lo digo en influencia no en el hecho
de que voy a buscarla no sé después de
todo lo del logo de banco el pichincha
no se dicen cómo voy a buscar tal cosa
no pero eso te genera recordación el
hecho de que las redes sociales tengan
hablándote de las cosas que banco
pichincha tiene tal cosa que tiene un
mba que tiene todo eso te genera que te
descargues una app y te integra con la
actividad de las redes sociales y por
eso es lo que estamos utilizando ahora
lo cierto
y sacaban ese link y ahora si pregunten
por favor que parece así soy bueno
después de explicar lo que desean saber
realmente del trabajo que mi trabajo
como involucra redes sociales y
pregunten por favor que en serio de lo
que dije en las oscuras estadísticas y
es como una presentación que les puedo
decir así pero quiero más enseñarles de
lo que he aprendido estos últimos diez
años he estado involucrado y si puede
ayudarle es mejor
pregunten
allí arriba perdón a ver
de abrir tu canal puedes abrir tu canal
sin ningún problema el problema es
cuando quieres monetizar tu canal cuando
tú abres tu canal no puedes monetizar
inmediatamente eres un usuario más de
youtube de youtube que simplemente puede
ver vídeos pero no puede monetizar
tienes que pasar un límite de
suscriptores y una cantidad de ingresos
para que la gente empieza a monetizar
porque es un negocio y hay que ser
honestos y tu canal no tiene nada no es
rentable por ende no te van a pagar
tienes que generar una marca y crear de
ti una marca en tu canal para que te
empiecen a pagar qué pasa que una cosa
de los bloqueos y la cosa de la censura
youtube siempre tuvo censura siempre
tuvo siempre haya bajista había una ley
de uso que leíamos y están los
reglamentos y te dice que puedes poner y
que no puedes poner siempre estuvo
simplemente que desde el año pasado
youtube se volvió mucho más estricto y
ahora sí estaba poniendo en uso su ley
de uso entonces obviamente hay
algoritmos que te detectan digamos y una
cabeza humana se me ve más de dos veces
y te borre vídeo
porque hay niños de 6 años que están
viendo sus vídeos y lamentablemente los
papás de hoy en día no les importa
simplemente es te mato youtube y me
entiendes entonces es por eso es que se
están implementando esas cosas para ver
si es que se mejore un poquito la raza
humana
realmente es por eso como es el pago el
pago viene se te paga un porcentual por
la
con los datos que pones básicamente son
marcas que contratas del contratan
directamente a ti tú puedes incluir tu
adn el vídeo en la parte de abajo o en
la parte lateral o puede ser gente que
se contacte directamente con youtube y
le dice quiero que me pongas en tal tipo
de contenido con tal tipo de alcance y
los manes de lorger logaritmo lo busca y
te pone directamente en el tuyo y de esa
cantidad de plata que paga la gente por
promocionar sus marcas un porcentaje
viene a ti porque la gente está viendo
ese vídeo y por ende están viendo esa
marca así es como funciona tú tienes una
pregunta
ya vamos en dos partes de esa pregunta
número uno no se olviden todo lo que
ustedes ven en redes sociales de
entretenimiento por ende no es real o
sea de verdad perdón que se le explique
la burbuja de esa forma pero todo lo que
ven en redes sociales la mayoría de
cosas que ustedes ven y monetiza ni
tienen publicidad y marcas no son reales
son cosas que están creadas para su
entretenimiento
porque si no no vemos tele nomás es que
es así entonces son así sí cuando estás
en youtube y creas contenido tienes que
buscar un personaje porque
lamentablemente todo todo todo recae en
la empatía y el carisma que puedes dar
con la gente y cuanto la gente se
identifica contigo entiendes la gente
los niños tal vez cuando yo soy así como
soy como me ven ahorita pero mucha gente
en mi canal se identifica mucha gente
parecida a mí se identifica conmigo
porque piensa parecido porque le gustan
algunas cosas que a mí me gustan porque
dice guau este chiquito viejo medio
peludo ya pues si él pudo yo también
puedo es por eso que están viendo me
perón
pero tienes que crear ese personaje
porque si no la gente no nomás es que
claro es como un show es un show si es
que si es que tu actuación no está al
nivel del guión la audiencia no lo ve
y eso es algo que tienes que crear y es
una cosa súper importante si van a ser
contenido que tiene que quedar contenido
que está a la altura de lo que ustedes
son muchas veces las personas que es una
cosa que a mí me frustró un montón veo
que hay gente que simplemente
sube contenido entiendes sube cualquier
cosa pero no no es no hay no hay una
producción detrás de eso más que fotos
bonitas no son fotos bonitas pueden ser
con cualquier aplicación hoy en día ya
pero la creación del contenido si
ustedes están aquí por eso si quieren
hacer contenido en contenido que les
guste ustedes que les hace que ustedes
que ustedes puedan hablar de verdad con
ese contenido de pasión porque cuando
ustedes hablan y eso la gente se va a
juntar a ustedes y vamos a ir creciendo
y si es como con el fútbol lo has visto
cómo se contagia el fútbol hay un hincha
y otro otro otro porque todo se mueve lo
mismo y es igualmente somos humanos
todos nos mueve lo mismo un corazón
respiramos tenemos emociones tenemos
anhelos tenemos sueños qué pasa si es
que tú te logras identificarte con una
presencia es guau yo quiero ser como esa
persona y esa persona es cool mira él
por su actitud logra hacer esas cosas o
mira tiene todo ese contenido o viaja o
eso es lo que tienes que crear para que
la gente te ve sino yo te ve y no tenía
trabajo
y con una parte me dijiste como yo
este es un conflicto super grande que
tuve por muchos años porque obviamente
tuvo cuando recién entré de este mundo
es como como le decía realizando que
venimos para acá es como al inicio
cuando estaba en el picón enchufe tipo
hablamos 2012 13 14
era muy chistoso porque todo el mundo
quería tate representó marcas en este
otro y obviamente eso eso en la cabeza
de una persona genera la presión de no
sabe mi personaje tiene que ser tal vez
de esta forma me entiendes o de esta
forma y simplemente me aburrí y cuando
abrí mi canal fue ok voy a ser yo y si
les gustaría y si no no me vean ya este
contenido pero es porque a la gente
y es todo porque siempre como un público
para cada persona pero siempre y cuando
lo hagas como sea
otra pregunta por allá arriba vinos
buenos preguntas
sabes que vi no no creo que por mi
personaje en general creo que es por lo
que hizo enchufe no creo que enchufe fue
como una abierta de ojos muy grande para
el ecuador diciendo si se puede de
verdad o soy no sólo en el fútbol
si podemos podemos poner ecuador en el
es que si perdón pero no me gusta el
fútbol únicamente el mundial porque eso
sí súper con ses y con eso sí me gusta
pero ponte a decir generar el fútbol no
lo veo pero pero es bueno saber que
podemos disfrutar en algo más que perder
un balón metiendo digo que está fácil
pero podemos hacer algo más y podemos
poner el ecuador en el mapa y por eso
haya gente en méxico dice chuta o cada
vez que viajas dice que significa chuta
esta vez éxitos de lado de otro país que
chuta como una expresión de wow
recórcholis eso
y ya se acabó el tiempo así que muchas
gracias por venir es que reprender ha
servido un poquito lo único que les
puedo decir para cerrar esto es que las
redes sociales en sí no es muy difícil
hace que sea si estás disputando un
negocio está pugnando a cualquier otra
cosa que no involucre tu personalidad tu
creación como un creador de contenido
hacerlas crecer es muy fácil tienes que
simplemente aprender los algoritmos las
horas que tienes que postear utiliza las
herramientas de las aplicaciones que
tienes y saber a qué público otras
apuntando no le vas a vender lechuga a
un niño de cinco años no va a comer
nunca lechuga ya entonces si es que hay
gente de marcas que está aquí el día de
hoy el único consejo que les puedo dar
en estos años que he tenido de
trayectorias sepan que quieren por favor
porque no saben que quieren tienen sus
objetivos pero los medios no los no los
ven claros y muchas veces no podemos
crear contenido o el creador de
contenido se ve como coartado porque
está en un en un drama de ok esto no es
mi contenido y ver en mi canal pero me
están pactando pero no no le hagan eso
al creador de contenido porque único
esta nación es un daño de la publicidad
ya la creación de universidad de este
país y segundo
si son creadores de contenidos en
originales sean auténticos no busquen la
fama la fama viene como una consecuencia
del trabajo duro por favor ya y gracias
me voy
[Aplausos]